what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with iron man and the the last
videos that we did it was kind of
interesting about this it is part of the
books of korvac but this is more of like
an interlude so what we might do in
order to keep things simple is we might
take this which is really the conclusion
of this little bit of an interlude we
might wrap it into the other two
episodes and make like a full story out
of it and then just throw it in the iron
man playlist to kind of keep things
simple so it's not overly complicated or
anything but while the main books of
korvac isn't necessarily done uh this
one has a great moment in this story so
much so that i kind of wanted to give it
my full attention which is why we're
sort of doing it on his own right i
don't really want to skim over anything
here but for those of you guys who are
getting caught up here the basis behind
what's happening in iron man right now
is that basically the villain michael
korvac has returned now a lot of people
who are familiar with marvel comics know
the name so bear with me for a second
for those who don't but michael korvac
is a very old villain in marvel comics
the quarterback saga is really one of
the seminal stories right it's one of
the most significant stories that model
comics had ever done but michael korvac
was basically a guy who ended up
attaining the power of godhood when he
essentially stole the power of galactus
and then ended up essentially fighting
the guardian of the galaxy from the year
3000 and then of course he also faced
off against the avengers right so it's a
really really significant story just in
terms of the marvel cosmic landscape
right the marble cosmic hierarchy but
what had essentially happened is that at
the beginning of this korvac had
returned and then looking to reattain
his level of godhood was traveling to
the ship of galactus known as tatu for
the purpose of stealing galactus power
yet again and so that's kind of where
things are in the moment tony stark and
really his ragtag teams like misty
knight and sam wilson and you know
frogman and a few other people have
basically been assembled in order to
track down uh michael korvac and defeat
him but tony stark was essentially
thrown into this planet with a with a
kind of disruption ray which was
basically being led by long-time villain
stiltman and that was one of the funny
things these are really obscure villains
here and christopher cantwell's doing
that across the board even michael
korvac's henchmen are like b-list
villains right like none of them are of
any real significance the controller
people like that it's not as though it's
like michael korvac leading a team of
like thanos and all these guys it's
b-list villains right the kind of people
you would expect to see somebody like
hawkeye face off against right just
nobody of any real significance here and
so what had happened is that prior to
this one of the occupants of this colony
a woman named yar had been killed by one
of the ultimo robots so of course that's
one of those giant robots that seems to
originate from this world and just kind
of travels around the landscape just
eating things right so it's very
reminiscent of like attack on titan
right it's not that dissimilar except in
the show you have titans and in this you
basically have you know giant robots
which for the longest time i always
thought the titans were giant robots i'm
still not convinced they're not but the
important thing here is that with yar
dying along with several other people of
course they're basically holding a
funeral and that's where tony is
struggling because he's talking with
colin who is essentially the the chief
security officer for stiltman who's a
combination of like the spiritual
leaders slash political leader i guess
of this colony and of course you know
colin kind of dealing with these these
you know issues and and so on the death
of people that they've basically grown
close with over time it hits them pretty
hard and that's when you have iron man
who basically goes and has a
conversation with stiltman and the funny
thing about this is that he asked him
he's like why don't we just destroy
these ultimo robots right like if these
robots are here i've already destroyed
one we can destroy all the others but
the the explanation offered by uh by
stiltman is that these things seem to
originate from just some singularity out
there somewhere right like some machine
creating other machines but we don't
know if they're coming in from like a
different different dimension we have no
idea how all this stuff works all we
know is that they just seem to appear
and they basically travel around the
landscape and then basically kill and
consume whatever it is they happen to
come across and so at the end of the day
like yes i love your your desire to help
here but what we're better off doing
here is focusing our efforts on creating
what is in essence a signal beacon right
something that can basically sit on an
sos into the universe and someone can
come and rescue us right because for
right now tony stark's kind of stranded
here and in the midst of this
conversation he has a stilt man suddenly
he's met by patsy walker now remember
patsy walker is a member of tony stark's
team and that while the the crew is
still on that ship tony stark was
basically yanked away and that's why
he's here and so as a result of this
patsy walker is basically communicating
to him through like the ship's
technology and where you would ask well
why don't they just come here and pick
up tony stark the explanation is given
to us and it's actually a pretty solid
explanation that's given here that where
tony stark doesn't necessarily ask like
why don't you come and pick me up the
explanation given by patsy walker is the
mission is more important than you right
michael korvac represents a clear and
present danger to the universe if he
gets to galactus world ship before we do
and we have no discernible means of
stopping him right like basically he
overpowers us and presumably even kills
us he'll steal the power of galactus and
things will be right back where they
were before right where he recreates
existence that was the significance of
the original quarterback saga michael
korvac was so powerful the only way to
defeat him was for him to end his own
life like literally he destroyed himself
in order to set everything back to the
way it was supposed to be in reality
mama kind of wrote themselves into a
hole but that's how powerful he was and
that's the level of power that we're
looking at again right a person who
really seemed to go insane with the
power of galactus being able to recreate
reality as they see fit and so what you
have here is patsy walker communicating
with tony and saying one i know you've
turned off your morphine regulator
because remember tony stark's neck is
broken that's why he's staying in his
iron man suit is because if he takes the
suit off like if he takes off his helmet
that's the end of him right i mean he
said like literally his his neck is
hanging on by a threat right his spine
if it moves in a millimeter in the wrong
direction either he'll die or he'll be
paralyzed from the neck down for the
rest of his life and so keeping his head
stationary by keeping the helmet on
that's the only thing that's keeping him
from experiencing that thing and so
because of that he's just kind of
keeping himself doped up on morphine all
the time which really throws in this
idea that tony stark's not necessarily
thinking clearly or rationally and when
he tells patsy walker when she says like
no no we're gonna go deal with
quarterback the response to tony is no
you can't do that right if you do that
you guys are going to get killed and
your deaths are going to be on my
conscience but patty walker makes a
really good point here she's like no you
can't take that approach right like this
is a choice that we're making and if you
say if we go and fight korvac we are
going to die and it's something you're
going to have to live with then it takes
away from the choice that we made but it
basically says like we are like like
mirrors of you we're reflections of you
right we we do what you would do we're
not really capable of making our own
intelligent rational decisions but we
know what we're doing we know that we're
going to go after michael korvac we know
he may very well kill us and we accept
that fact right it's our role as heroes
to put the safety of individuals or
universes or the planet or what have you
ahead of our own lives to be willing to
make that sacrifice and so following
that tony stark becomes kind of
suspicious of everything stiltman was
saying and then offering this
explanation that like these machines are
coming from some singularity out there
the fact that they don't really know a
whole lot about them and so on and so
forth and so what he does is of course
he sneaks off to one of the machines and
when he gets to the ultimo robot he's
immediately attacked by colin and the
reason why is because as the head of
security colin wasn't really given the
details he was just told by uh by
stiltman make sure nobody gets close to
these things now the explanation i
imagine was probably offered if one was
even offered at all like assuming what
actually happened is well if you mess
with it it could send out a beacon to
the other ultimo robots and they would
all descend on us right like you would
bring death and destruction down on us
more so than that the citizens of this
colony trust stiltman implicitly they
don't really have a reason to question
him and so because of that they just
sort of go with whatever it is that he
says but tony stark knows enough about
wilbur to know he was a villain and so
while he may be telling the truth tony
stark's approaching this from the
perspective of trust but verify and so
when he shows up here and he's
immediately attacked by colin that tips
them off that either colin is working
with him or colin doesn't know what's
going on and so where tony stark gets
the upper hand on colin is like what are
you hiding here what's going on that's
when colin spills the beans like look
i'm just doing what i was told i was
told to make sure that nobody got close
to this thing i don't even know why why
all i know is wilbur said something
about like the the balance is fragile or
something along those lines and so as
tony stark starts going through this
ultima robot and investigating it what
he finds is that it's actually being
controlled remotely right there's like
an ir circuit right an infrared circuit
this thing's being controlled and so
that's when he realizes stiltman is the
one that's doing this now here's the
great thing about this and this is what
i loved about the way that christopher
cantwell handled this this is one of
those moments when anybody could have
just been like well stilt man did it
because he's a villain and still man's
like absolute power like that kind of a
thing instead it's this great
philosophical argument you guys know i
love these kinds of these kinds of
positions these kind of discussions it's
this right that when tony stark runs up
on stiltman and is like you're the one
controlling these ultimo robots you're
the one bringing them here you're the
one that's causing problems here you
know literally the one that's getting
people killed the response of stiltman
is essentially a small price to pay in
order to maintain the balance this is
game theory in fact if we want to go
with an example that's probably more
familiar to you let's look at star wars
knight to the old republic right i don't
know if you guys ever played that game
but when you're looking for the star map
on kashyyyk you're kind of given these
different game theory type scenarios
right the prisoner's dilemma different
things like that one of the questions is
this it says imagine you are the leader
of a nation consider enemy states to be
weak and remote with no external threat
your empire stagnates your people become
complacent and then they begin to
question you however in your
investigation of this attack you
discover a weakness that would come
after the attack and that weakness would
actually allow you to destroy the enemy
once and for all what do you do and the
answer to that scenario is you allow the
attack to happen because the people
would rally under you against a common
foe and that's really what stilt man is
talking about here now the reality is
still man's also engineering these
attacks but what it does is it unifies
the community and saying those ultimos
are a threat so long as we focus on
trying to find a way to get out of here
then everything will be okay now of
course the idea of sending out some kind
of an sos beacon that's sort of
a feeling of comfort and safety the hope
that comes with that would only last for
so long but that's why you would have to
generate a new thing for them to rally
around and then a new thing after that
and a new thing after that that where
stiltman considers them to be part of
this ecosystem essentially he also had
his own personal ambitions which was to
prove that he could be a leader to prove
the idea that having individuals who
live these lives where there is no real
external threat out there and that in
the absence of any kind of external
threats that people would live up to
their fullest potential that that's
actually not true that if people are
given the opportunity to do whatever it
is they want to do with their lives and
to live their lives however they see fit
that they would ultimately grow to
become stagnant that they would either
do everything there was to do or they
would do nothing but the idea of having
this sort of external threat out there
that's always looming on the horizon
that while it does cause a bit of stress
and anxiety among the people it also
unifies them because if they're focusing
on an enemy they're not focusing on each
other and once that enemy goes away then
that's when differences start to crop up
that's when you don't believe what i
believe or you don't think what i think
right you don't feel the same way that i
feel about these things therefore you
are the bad guy that's how you end up
with strife and civil war so it's
actually a very smart maneuver on his
behalf to be willing to sacrifice some
innocent lives in order to maintain the
cohesiveness of the overall community i
mean is that philosophy a little bit
ruthless sure but it cannot be argued
that the philosophy works and so it's a
pretty interesting concept now of course
iron man and those guys basically end up
overcoming stiltman why they managed to
defeat him and that's basically it but
in the midst of him pleading his case to
them and telling them what's going on
that he essentially engineered a
circumstance whereby innocent people
would be killed in order to satisfy the
the livelihood of the greater whole that
all these individuals who have overheard
it kind of descend back into their own
selfish motivations where the response
is how dare you sacrifice innocent lives
to maintain this entire community and to
keep it from falling into a state of
civil war right what's your problem
and so all these guys basically descend
on stilt man carry them away presumably
to to kill him or destroy him or
whatever the case happens to be but the
crazy thing about this is that as colin
and iron man are basically leaving
suddenly tony stark's met by the most
unexpected person which is the living
tribunal and the living tribunal
literally just appears here and says
tony stark right and tony's just kind of
shocked like holy cow the lady tribunal
just appeared to me right but the
tribunal says the universe is on the
verge of catastrophic imbalance only you
can restore this balance you must travel
to the world ship of galactus at this
very moment now here's the reality of
this this is one of the shortcomings of
christopher cantwell and not even just
him the shortcoming of marvel comics in
relation to how they use the living
tribunal where iron man replies and says
so from what you're telling me my
friends will not be able to stop korvac
on their own i have to do it the
response of the tribunal is you gravely
misunderstand my words but you still
must leave right now and tony stark says
okay fine i'll do it but you need to
return all these people back to their
home which of course the living tribunal
does and then teleports iron man and
avro back to the or over to the world
ship of tattoo the world ship of
galactus here's the problem with how
marvel handles the living tribunal back
in the day when the tribunal was a major
player in marvel comics and i'm not even
talking about like his first appearance
with doctor strange even then he wasn't
even fully fleshed out he's like i
represent god or something like that and
like i do some stuff like the reality is
that as time progressed marvel flushed
his character out more and gave him an
actual role to exist in which is to
maintain balance of the universe and
that normally whenever there was any
kind of imbalance the tribunal would
either be requested by the various
cosmic entities like what you saw during
infinity gauntlet when they asked him to
rule against thanos and the response of
the tribunal was no thanos attaining the
infinity stones and then assembling the
gauntlet that's just a natural part of
the universe they exist in this universe
he's not abusing his power furthermore
if the goal of thanos is to take over to
basically destroy eternity and replace
him that's the natural order of things
right the weak make way for the strong
it'd be different if he had kind of
gotten some energy source from outside
the universe and then brought it into
the universe then that creates an
imbalance but using the tools the
universe provides in order to expand its
own power that's just the way it goes
but either it would be a situation like
that or it would be something like from
the the protege storyline where protege
had this level of power where he could
duplicate the powers of anybody and that
it would be different if he was born
that way but the reality is he was
engineered to be that way and so because
of that it violated the natural order of
things creating these kind of standards
by which the the tribunal lives and the
tribunal steps in it's weird to see the
tribunal show up and say yes tony stark
i am the walking talking embodiment of
the multiverse and i can wipe out whole
universes with a wave of my hand but
only you can stop michael korvac right i
mean it's it's like the rain telling
humanity only you can stop forest fires
right it doesn't make any sense right
why don't you do that rain it's kind of
what you do but that's kind of the way
the character has been portrayed over
the years if i'm being honest with you
guys the most recent and faithful
depiction of the tribunal came during
jonathan hickman's avengers new avengers
and it's not because i'm just a huge fan
of that story but it's because the
beyonders in the multiverse killing
cosmic entities it's like some kind of a
virus in the human body it's a foreign
threat and so the living tribunal
stepping in and trying to destroy the
beyonders it makes the most practical
sense it's what it's supposed to do and
so the result of this is that the
tribunal has kind of been misused over
the years he's really sort of been
turned into a plot device more so than
anything else so while it is cool to see
the tribunal here the significance of
the tribunal being here has kind of been
lost on comic book readers over the
years because it's almost like the
tribunal kind of plays the role of a
watcher now right where when the
tribunal pops up i mean he's not going
to do anything but you know something
big is about to happen right and that's
that's really kind of how those things
go so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end uh we
will continue this once they actually
finish the story uh once christopher
cantwell finishes what's basically this
next part then we'll kind of continue
that uh and then we'll call it a day so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace